-It's been such a great year
for you
since the last time
you were here.
You won the Emmy,
you won the Golden Globe,
but on Saturday,
you had one of the biggest
things happen.
You were impersonated on
"Saturday Night Live."
-Yeah.
-And Cecily Strong did you.
And here is Aidy Bryant
as Amy Sherman-Palladino.
And you tweeted about it.
You seemed very --
Were you very excited?
-I still feel that way.
-Yeah.
-I'm still making that face.
Just...
-And so, you did not
see it live, correct?
Someone else --
-No. I was abroad,
and so I was six hours ahead.
And everyone I have ever met
had sent me a text message
by the time I woke up
the next morning.
-And then, do you go
into it with nerves?
Because, obviously, people
get impersonated on it.
This was done with love.
Sometimes they're not.
Yeah.
-Yeah, absolutely.
-Other people were tweeting
about "SNL" this week,
and they were less happy.
-They were not so thrilled about
that, yeah.
No. I mean, even if
it had been terrible,
I feel like I still
would have been thrilled.
-That's great.
That is right way to go into it.
One of the coolest things
about season two
is it opens in Paris,
and this is not
sound stage Paris.
You guys actually
got to go to Paris.
I mean, was that just so
exciting to shoot there?
-It was amazing and so strange
to start the season that way.
-Yeah.
-New York is a character
in the show.
And so, to begin season two in
Paris, we were very confused.
But it was amazing.
We ate all the baguettes.
We drank all the wine.
-Yeah.
-And we had a great time.
It was like "Maisel" camp
in Paris.
-You got to shoot a scene
where you were doing stand-up
and you had a French translator.
What -- How --
That was also fantastic.
-Wasn't she amazing?
-She was great, yeah.
-She was so talented.
She came in for this --
She was actually --
She got the job because
she did such a beautiful job
just reading the part
at the table read.
And she jumped in.
And I didn't think there were
very many people out there
who can speak as fast as I can,
but Leslie gave me
a run for my money.
-That's good.
In another language no less.
-Yeah, exactly.